[Music]
you must have had
a smart idea about the biometrics you
must have looked at
everything because of your physics
background you'd have an engineering
you'd have dismantled
the whole event and then rebuilt it in
your
style in your form that gave you surely
did you have an unfair advantage is what
i'm
saying we need to outlaw physics because
people will have an advantage
yeah it's called a fair
advantage that's what it is i um i
taught myself to run
well 13 hurdles i was a very good high
hurdler i was running like 13
six and uh i dropped my 400 flat down so
just
just to be clear that would be the 110
meter height 110 yeah yeah
i went 110 and then i ran from from my
sophomore year to my junior year
i won the conference in 47.5 and i felt
like i had made it in track and field
well at the first meet of my junior year
which was 76 at the florida relays
um i started the season with a 46-1 so
that was like a second
and a half a drop right from the
beginning
and then when i ran the 400 hurdles for
the first time
um i had been doing a lot of power
running cross-country running so i was
in tip-top condition
all i had to do was teach myself how to
run the hurdles
35 meters apart and the first time i did
it i found myself running 13
and i found myself using my left leg
which is the inner leg
13 strides between the two steps yeah
yeah
running closer to the curve and then i
figured out that if i run
eight inches away from the inner line
which is where they measure the lane
versus uh you know two or three feet in
the middle of the lane i'm saving
three to four meters per race which is
like 15 feet
anywhere from 12 to 15 feet so that was
the first adjustment i made
wait edwin are you saying that the
effective
length of your path because you start
out
in blocks right right and
of course you have to stay in your lane
because that you were hurdle all the way
around
so the length the actual 400 meters
is not the center line of the width of
your lane eight inches
eight inches from the inner line i
didn't know that eight inches from the
inner line so my
endeavor was to run as close to as that
as close to the inner line as i could
whereas most people just run all over
the lane and by doing that i calculated
the radius of the track and figured it
out that i was saving
three to four meters per race so that's
12 15 feet
and i was i was basically that that
that's some unfair advantage that's a
huge that's a that's a lot
distance that's some unfair advantage
there damn edwin
that's not nice
so everyone was always asking me what
the secret was but i would never talk
about something as simple as that
they thought it was you know
whatever it could be but it was a
combination of 13 steps
i was a very good technician i ran with
my uh
inner leg my left leg my left leg was
the one that i went over the hurdle
first so i was able to run
closer to the line which got me 12 to 15
feet in every race
and that was the first thing on my mind
coming out of the blocks if you ever see
me come out of the blocks i'm running
almost on the line around those turns
wait wait wait wait wait you indulge me
for one second wait just
just a quick check so if if you take 13
steps that's an odd number of steps
right so you're saying your left leg
only took you over the first hurdle but
your right leg is going to take you over
the second one
no left leg every time because they
don't count the step when you touch down
they don't count that one they count the
following one
so oh an odd number of steps will
will have you hurtling on the same leg
an even number you would switch
you switch wow anyone wonder why he was
world champion
yeah so what you're saying is wait wait
so if you go over with your
left leg yeah and since we all run
counterclockwise around the tracks
that left leg assures you that you will
be
closer to the line eight inches because
like you're landing somewhere else
exactly oh my god i love this
you've got to learn if you run with your
right leg for example
uh your body has to remain within the
vertical plane of 48 inches the lanes
are 48 inches wide so if your knee
swings outside of the lane technically
you can get uh
eliminated from the race it's a file
that's a foul
and they will call it in the olympic
games because those guys who
who run with their right leg going over
first and their left leg is what they
call hooking
going outside of the light or even under
the plane of the hurdle
sometimes speaking of that speaking of
fouls well just to be clear your knee
just
just just your your front leg goes
straight out and over
and then your trailing legs
there's a whole drag motion there right
that's that has width to it and that's
what you're describing
that's right it's exiting the lane
that's right and if it exits the lane
that can be a penalty but if your left
leg you don't have to worry about it and
you're running
inside right so let me ask you this um
and i will show my ignorance because
i've always been
uh just too afraid to ask this question
when you see the guys running and
they're knocking over all the hurdles
okay they're being penalized for that
because every time i watch
hurdlers and i see them knocking over
the hurdles
i'm like well that guy sucks i could do
that
he's just knocking stuff over well
the federation the federation did a
trick on that because when i was running
i think it took
18 to 20 pounds to tip over a high a
high hurdle it would take 20 pounds of
force to knock it over
they reduced that to 12. so uh during
roger kingdom's
era and he won two gold medals those
guys were knocking over hurdles every
time in my
era they had big lead weights on it one
was flipped forward and one was flipped
back
if you hit any hurdle it would it would
take away from
chuck it had to go there he's saying in
my day
it snowed in both directions and i
we had it hard okay keep whining
they had to change the rules to keep up
with the old dogs that's what they did
there you go guys so basically that's
what they did
and with the track surfaces as well they
changed the bouncy the
elasticity of the track to make our
times faster
so how did you cope with that because
you went from what i would call cinder
track
to uh we call it tartan it's a yeah it's
terrible
yeah and that obviously energy rebounds
back out of that so
you being the engineer how did you cope
with the effect that that had
in your technique because you always say
about the most important thing being
the take off yeah so first before you
before you do that maybe there's
somebody listening who's like me
who is not a track aficionado like you
three
who doesn't and doesn't know what a
cinder track and a tartan is
all right okay rubber track the tracks
you see now the rubberized surfaces
that's what that's what he means it's a
trade name there's about three different
names uh
mondo tartan uh
recortan there's quite a few brand names
but they're all essentially rubber and
they all have a standardized
uh compound that they must have i ran on
dirt tracks in dayton ohio
it was cinder basically it was here it
is again i was on dirt tracks and my
hurdles wouldn't it was ground up
senders and sand
yeah and they would take uh they would
spike it up and get a tractor to roll it
down so it's almost like uh
like you would see on a at a
construction site right before they
begin to put up everything it's just
rolled flat and heavy
and we used to wear these long
three-quarter inch spikes in it
the problem with that is when you're
behind uh you literally eat dirt the
people
in front of you are kicking up dust and
sand and you know it gets in your teeth
and in your eyes
but uh the first time i ran on a
rubberized track with with great shoes
was in the 1976 olympic games
i had first time you ran on that well
one of those trips well the first time i
ran where i really really felt the
difference when i got
brand new shoes that were made by adidas
and they were custom-made for the
olympic games and
the olympic track which was a lot bigger
and just perfect for running
i felt like i i just felt like a ferrari
and uh with big wheels on
it the total amount of grip that you
could get the elasticity when you
take off i mean you could feel the
energy coming out of the track
if you put it in so when i felt that in
montreal and ran around that track i
just knew it was going to be all over
and the spikes are shorter for the pla
for the rubberized track correct yeah
they're they're like mine with like nine
millimeters something like that like a
quarter of an inch
less than a half of an inch right right
yeah now see this is where
this is where on my feet it was all over
as far as i was concerned
that's confidence right there
bye